well actually the title song is is a
very personal song I I got very sick
three years ago and I had to torpedo my
upcoming tour for the record just before
this and it took me a long time to get
better and during that recovery time I
really went through a period where I
didn't know when I was going to resume
my career writing songs was something of
an act of faith because I didn't know
when I would send them out into the
world or if or how or whatever and
everything was kind of up in the air and
the first verse of the that song is all
about just kind of burying my head under
the covers and just you know forgetting
how to dream for getting out to connect
with the world and and then if you can
somehow find it in yourself to to take
that cover off your head and look around
into the world and see that there is so
much to be there's so much to draw
strength from two to be inspired by to
derive love from abiding love and
strength and confidence that's what
helped me feel like I could come back
and and be in the world again and the
chorus is you know in an age of miracles
there's is there one on the way it sort
of asking the question and two I get
something up a paraphrase of CSO the
idea that you know we live in an age of
miracles if we still believe that their
possible the song speaks to a lot of
sort of current events in our last few
years but those are the things that
connect us all and give us courage and
give us our purpose
Wow well I think I'm still processing
that experience three years later but
certainly initially what got me through
is my family and my friends and my
husband and and just their care and
their love and support when I felt
pretty lost and its seed with with
everything that had happened
absolutely the most terrifying part of
it was just before they they found it
when I was in the ER and I couldn't
breathe and was in such terrible pain
and didn't know why so you know at that
moment you're not sure what's going to
happen next and if you're going to be
there for so that was the most
terrifying moment I still think about
that experience in the ER and it's
almost hard to think about if I ruminate
about it too much it sets me back so I
try not to go there too often and it's
just you know recovering is just a long
slow process and again without the help
of friends and family and just wonderful
doctors it just would have been so
difficult
well this record is a very quiet record
and I think there's a reason for that
it's I had I wanted to write about what
what had happened and how it felt and
the effect it had on my life and my
relationships and everything and it's
not a big stomp around you know muscular
kind of subject it's it's something that
that that I I knew this record would be
a much more of a sort of meditative
record and but at the same time it is a
record of Optimus and ultimately of
optimism and sort of coming out of
adversity and that's much to celebrate